everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today they're gonna be
looking at the evans game it's
specifically the decline line so the
evans game at pawnee for pawnee v 9 f3
knight c6 and then getting the bishops
involved into the game and then playing
the pawn here to b4 you're looking to
give up material so after the bishop
takes which is the most common and the
Evans gambit so then play pawn to c3 and
after the bishop moves to them play pawn
to d4 trying to control the center of
the board so that's the Evans gambit
there's another video on that but I
thought it'd be good to go in depth into
the decline lines because again a lot of
times your opponents don't go for the
decline that you want and it's very
important to understand how to react if
they don't go for the gambit first thing
that you could see is Bishop to d4 or if
we look at this we can pretty much
already tell that if they're not going
to take the pawn the bishops gonna have
to move or the bishops gonna fall so
Bishop to b4 is an option this is gonna
be pretty easy for white pawn here to
see three White's in a much better
position he still has the pawn here on
before and he's continuing his same play
as before pawn here to c3 pushing
forward with pawn here to the four
getting ready to castle on the kingside
controlling the center of the board it's
gonna be a pretty easy game for white
not very common another more common move
that you will see is bishop back here to
d6 now this is still pretty good for
white again he still has this pawn here
on b4 this bishop is really blocking off
a lot of the development from the Queen
side from black this pawn on here on d7
can't really move it's kind of awkward
which makes this LightSquared bishop
it's not gonna be doing anything for a
long time black is pretty much forced to
castle on the Kings side and kind of
develop he's gonna be playing Knight to
f6 pretty soon white can just continue
with the same game plan if he wants to
pawn here to c3 you can castle on the
Kings side he can continue pretty easy
from here now there's a few ways that
white can actually continue in this
particular case he could play pawn here
to b5 could be followed by Knight here
to a5 and then you can kind of bring
this back here if you wanted here
you could play Bishop to e2 that's one
way to go about it a move that I like a
little bit
better is after the bishop comes here to
d6 is pawn here to a3 and then after
Knight here to f6 then we have pawn here
to d3 now it's a little bit different
but if you kind of look at this this is
extremely easy for white to play he has
nice pawn chains even over here with his
pawn here on a 3 and B 4 this is really
nice he can castle on the kingside he
can play a knight here to c3 get it
involved into the game he has a nice
long way for his bishop to control if he
ever needed to kick it back his bishop
can come here to b2 and kind of reign
supreme over this long diagonal or it
can easily get developed over here this
is probably the easiest way for white to
continue because he has so many options
and it's really hard for black to really
stop a lot of this because there's so
many different avenues
so again if you see this you can take
the aggressive approach and kind of push
forward with pawn to b5 but it's much
easier if you just stick with pawn to a3
and then kind of change things up a
little bit you don't really have to put
more pressure on the center or just play
pawn here to d3 and you can develop from
there another common move that you'll
see is the bishop coming back here to e7
they're probably not going to come back
here to f8 that would just be terrible
losing so much time in space but Bishop
here to e7 is fine because they can
still bring Knight here to f6 pretty
safe defense and then castle on the King
side from here why it's gonna play
similar as you did before is gonna play
pawn here to a3 again protecting his
pawn here on b4 also allowing him to
play bishop here to be to knight here to
c3 really leaves the door open for a lot
of what he wants to do if we see Knight
here to f6 same thing as before we're
gonna change it up a little bit and play
pawn here to d3 opening up those avenues
from here we could see black pushing
forward more than times and then not
you'll see the Keane castling on the
King side but you could see the pawn
coming here to to d5 after the exchange
you have the Knights then the bishop can
just come to let's say b2 all of a
sudden White has a pretty good attack he
has both of his bishops just eyeing down
these long diagonals he can cast on the
king's head pretty easy
get his rook over here on e1 controlling
the semi open file starting to put a lot
of pressure on the blacks King side
which right now it looks like he's going
to castle but he may change his mind
knowing that he has so much pressure
from white the most common variation
that you'll see the one that we're gonna
be talking about the most because you'll
see it more often than not is the bishop
coming back here to b6 it still puts a
lot of pressure on this long diagonal
attacking the square here on F 2 which
is weakness for White's early on to the
game the king is the only piece that
protects it so a lot of times black will
put it here on b6 trying to maintain
this pressure over here and it's
important that white understands how to
attack this because if he doesn't attack
it correctly it can go very very bad for
white white needs to play pawn here to
a4 kind of look at it it's pretty
interesting white is looking to attack
on the Queen side his next move if he
could we'll just be pawn here to a5
pretty much threatening to take this
bishop without much concession black has
to kind of respond there's a few ways
that you can respond so it's good from
here to kind of talk about how black can
respond one way is he could now take
this pawn here on b4 with his knife we
are talking about if he doesn't take it
the pawn right away in the evidence game
it but it is very possible to go ahead
and take with his knight right here why
it's not gonna push forward with pawn
here to a5 whereas the bishop go doesn't
have too many options we could see the
bishop come here to d4 and then we see
pawn here to c3 so that's gonna be bad
probably not gonna see that too often
because that's gonna give up one of
these minor pieces another thing that
you could see more common is Bishop here
to c5 makes more sense but we're going
to be doing the same thing the pawn is
going to come here to c3 after the
knight moves we could see the knight
coming to a6
this seems pretty logical then the King
can castle on the King side so if we
look at it White's giving up some
material but he has a much better game
in this particular case let's say we
look at it from here this Knight can't
move so let's say the knight comes to f6
if we kind of go through this now white
can push forward with d4 starting to put
even more pressure on the center of the
board he
easily get all of his pieces bottom to
the action his queen can swing wherever
he wants to
he's already castled his white bishop is
destroying this long diagonal he can
easily get his not involved his dark
square bishop so it has a lot of
different options from here so if we
look at it we see okay let's have this
pawn take here on d4 and then the pawn
takes where does black go from here a
few options you could play Bishop here
too before the Queen can now come here
to b3 this starts to get very
complicated for black eyeing down the
square here on f7 he does have two
attackers the next move if he wanted he
can play Knight here to g5 have three
attackers on f7 so it's going to be very
difficult for black to kind of respond
to all these if instead of coming to
before he could play Bishop here to d6
again it kind of stops some of what we
talked about as far as the pawn coming
for but this is gonna be bad as you can
imagine with pawn here to e5 that's
something gonna be a mistake can also
bring his bishop back here to e7 we've
already talked about bringing it back
here to f8 is kind of a mistake but
after East 7 forward with E 5 now had
his black respond to this he could play
Knight here to e4 again this Queen here
to b3 is gonna be very difficult to deal
with he could bring it over here Knight
to h5 but again Knight to g5 starts to
get very very tricky as far as how black
responds this is kind of opening up an
attack here on the night on h5 so even
if the bishop takes now the Queen takes
here on h5 again this is threatening not
only this Bishop here on g5 but it's
also threatening mate in one with Queen
ticking here on f7 so that's going to be
very difficult even if the knight comes
to a pretty aggressive square of Knight
to g4 pretty simple y can just play pawn
here to h3 forcing the knight to move
the knight can't come back here to have
six we talked about if it does come back
here to h6 the Bishop can take after we
have this exchange rights here then we
have Knight to c3 if we kind of look at
this board right here White's giving up
some material but he's just dominating
this game this is an overwhelming
victory for white
as all of his pieces developed his queen
can get involved this night overhears
not doing much of anything the kingside
were black really wants to castle is
just completely decimated and white has
free reign to kind of do what he wants
to it's gonna be very difficult for
white or black to get many of his pieces
developed this Queen can't move for a
few moves this light square bishop can't
go anywhere this Knight can't really go
anywhere productive and this rook over
here in a it's not gonna be moving for a
long time so this particular situation
is very very good for white now if we
step back a few moves we look at this we
talked about what happens if the knight
comes to a6 but the knight doesn't have
to come to a6 he could come to c6 in
this variation this is actually my
favorite variation because y can get
pretty aggressive typically you want to
play pawn to c3 and then push forward
with the pawn to d4 but after the pawn
takes here white doesn't have to
recapture instead he can go ahead and
castle on the Kings side again when you
play a gambit you try to be pretty
aggressive you don't mind giving up some
material because you know you're gonna
have a strong attack so after this pawn
takes we look at this board White's
giving up a decent amount of material
he's down to pawns and material but he's
dominating this board
he's already castled blacks a few moves
away from castling it's gonna be very
difficult to castle on the Queen side
he's gonna be way too far behind to do
that if he tries to castle on the King
side Knight here to f6
we could play pawn here to e5 forcing
this knight to move let's say the knight
comes over here to g4 then white has
Queen here to d5 which is an interesting
move because typically you don't have
the Queen just reign supreme but because
of this openness
y can really dominate with his bishops
he can dominate with this Queen this is
threatening mate right here on f7 if
black decides to castle now for safety
black's gonna lose material and now all
of a sudden white's dominant not only a
material but in the center of the board
now it doesn't have to castle you could
see the Queen coming here to e7
but now the bishop can just swing in
here to g5 it's being protected by the
knight so the Queen can't really do too
much if the pawn comes down here to f6
trying to block this off we just have
the pawn take right here on f6
this is not only threatening but if this
Queen moves white can potentially take
over here on c5 he can also swing his
rook over here to e1 threatening both
the Queen and the King so this is again
putting more and more pressure on black
this is gonna be very very good for
white now if we come back to the
beginning after pawn to a4 another
variation that you may see is pawn to a6
still allowing for the bishop to come
back here to a7 so we can still control
this long diagonal this is gonna be
completely fine there's actually an
attack that you can play in this that I
really like it's called the conquest
attack and it's Knight here to see 3
after the knight comes to f6 which is
the most common move for black because
he wants to go ahead and castle so he
can get some safety anytime you're
playing against the game but you want to
get King safety because you just don't
know what your opponent is necessarily
gonna do why can push forward with pawn
to d4 pretty calm and trying to control
the center of the board but the only
difference is after the pawn takes here
on d4 White's not gonna swoop in with
Knight here to d5 but again this is the
Quon conquest attack it's only four
players that want to be super aggressive
so let me just throw that out there it
can get pretty crazy if you want to play
more of a slow subtle game this is
definitely not gonna be the attack for
you but you're typically not going to be
playing the Evans gambit in the first
place so from here we could see the
knight taking on e4 first this is one
option we can now see castle we can see
castle then the brook could swing over
here to e1 starting to put pressure this
is gonna be completely fine more common
than that is for the night just to go
ahead and take here on d5 after this
we're just gonna see the pawn take very
important that you capture with the
right material so the pawn taking
instead the bishop this is important a
few things from here the knight could
take on before just trying to go over
all the different options from here we
could have castle on both sides of the
board and we could have Bishop coming
over here to d5 very active position
from white right here another thing that
you could see after the pawn comes here
is the Queen coming here to e7
threatening the King right here forcing
him to move and why it's actually okay
with moving his King here too
f-1 out looks kind of funny because yes
white would like to castle on the
kingside but he's not too worried he can
still get some counter play in this
particular game after this the knight
could come over here to e5 again it is
being attacked by this pawn so he does
want to move somewhere it could be a
little weaker if he decides to take here
on before so you could to see this
knight coming over here to e5 putting
more pressure but now there's an
interesting move that white has and you
can play pawn here to d6 now if the
Queen takes this is probably going to be
worse for black now we can have the
bishop coming over here to f4 pinning
down this material here the knight can't
move in take because it's gonna fall but
there's now two attackers on the square
right here now we could see the pawn
coming to f6 trying to add a defender on
the square right here but then after the
exchange this is gonna be completely
fine for white because he can swoop in
with Queen to h5 all of a sudden there's
too much pressure and he also has
another attacker right here on the
square on e5 if instead of taking with
the Queen he now decides to take with
his pawn here on these six now I can
play bishop here to d5 and it gets
pretty interesting right here white is
down material but black has a lot of
things that he has to be cautious about
he has triple pawns on the D file so
that's not that great although he is
able to take back this pawn on d4 if
white wants to he does have two
attackers right here but this bishop on
d5 is kind of a pain it's gonna be very
difficult for black to deal with his
light square Bishop on c8 isn't going
anywhere and because it's not going
anywhere
again this bishop even blocks this pawn
from moving blocking this pawn from
moving because his bishops not moving
this rook over here is networking is not
moving as well if you've seen any other
videos you know it's not always about
the pieces you have is about the pieces
you have in the fight y can really use a
lot of his pieces where black just can't
do a whole lot so if we look at this
with particular case after the Bishop to
d5 we can have castling over here we
could have the bishop coming over here
to g5
aggressive the only really move from
here is to play Queen to e8 something
else instead of castling on the the King
side a lot of times you'll see the Queen
trying to move so Queen here to f6 from
now we could play Knight here to g5
pretty aggressive we can now have
castling on the King side but now
White's gonna try something different
because he has played this pawn here to
a4 he can now play rook over here to a3
and they can start to swing his rook and
really get it involved into the action
now this is somewhat tough for black to
deal with he could try pawn here to h6
kind of forcing this night away right
here but that's gonna be completely fine
we can just play a knight here to e4
threatening the Queen right here where
the Queen moves from here is actually
very important the Queen pretty much has
to play f5 if he doesn't move that five
he's kind of in a lot of trouble if he
moves Queen over here to d8 then the
rook to g3 is gonna be very tough to
deal with
again White has a lot of threats he can
get his Queen involved he can play
Bishop taking on page six and can't
recapture because this rook right here
he's also threatening with his bishop
peeking it anytime it get his knight
involved into the game so they're gonna
be tough to deal with if the Queen just
comes back here to e7 same kind of thing
it's still gonna be tough the rook can
swing over here to h3 if he wants to
again threatening this material over
here if the Queen comes to let's say h4
we're gonna see the same thing coming
back here to h3 no great squares
probably the best square for the Queen
is to come to f5 from now the rooks
going to swing over here to d3
threatening the material as well again
putting a lot of pressure on the square
on g7 black could try to stop it with
Knight here to g7 or GC excuse me this
is one option from here it's gonna get
kind of interesting we're now gonna play
Queen here to f3 and it's just kind of
bonkers from here so again a very
aggressive line from White's
black over here still trying to figure
out how he's gonna get his material
involved into the game this Bishop here
on d5 but only controls the serum the
bored but it pretty much stops - of
blacks pieces from pretty much doing
anything in this particular game it's
very important again in this particular
conquest attack that you understand what
you're trying to do you're trying to
attack the kingside and at the same time
you're trying to thwart any development
that black has on the queenside so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video a
lot of different variations a lot of
stuff to talk about in the Evans gambit
hopefully these are all the variations
that you'll see in the decline line I
myself obviously like the accepted line
but hopefully if you do play the evans
game but this will definitely give you
some insight into how to play correctly
if they don't accept the line so enjoy
the video and I'll see you on the next
one thanks for watching